hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today are going to be
starting our coverage of the 2014 chess
olympiad
is actually played every two years my
favourite tournament because it's a
little bit different than most chess
tournaments which are all individual
performances the chess olympiad
actually by countries there's about 170
countries represented each country has
five players in each round we have two
weeks of chess er which is pretty cool
but in each round the country can pick
four of their players to go up against
four players from another country it's a
Swiss style format so each round you're
playing someone that has equal as far as
their results in the previous round so
even though you're not gonna play all
169 other countries you'll be playing
other countries they're doing about as
well as you so really really cool
formats I'm gonna try to hop around and
do as much coverage as I can there's
gonna be hundreds if not thousands of
matches throughout these this two-week
span so I'll try to do as many as
possible but our first match today that
we're gonna be going over is why it's
gonna be played by Oscar de la Riva and
he's actually from Andorra if you're not
too familiar with that northeast part of
Spain and then on the black side is
gonna be played by a nice giri he's 20
years old he's Dutch he's in my opinion
one of the the up-and-coming players
that could potentially challenge Magnus
Carlsen in a few years so I thought it'd
be cool the Netherlands is kind of my my
Dark Horse to go ahead and win this
tournament though probably in the top 10
maybe 10 or 11th as far as overall teen
country that can compete but I think
they have a chance that they've got some
some youngsters some youth on their team
that I think they can actually win this
tournament so that's we're gonna be
going over today hopefully you guys
enjoy it Oscar de la riva playing the
white pieces starts out with pawn to e4
pawn to c5 from a niche the Sicilian
defence Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5
and then we see a pawn to g6 being keto
on the kingside castle and then Bishop
here to g7 now it's always fun
especially in the earlier rounds you
have different players playing each
other sometimes a very very different in
skill level this particular match a
niche is about 200 points higher than
his opponent but in some of these
matches
you have 1100 point disparity in points
because there's so many countries some
of these countries don't have a lot of
extremely talented players so it's
always fun to watch but this particular
case we have two grandmasters that are
very very solid at chess so we should
expect a pretty good match here a rook
to e1 getting behind this pawn here on
e4 Knight to f6 Black's just developing
as pieces like normal the next move from
white is pretty interesting in its pawn
here to c3 now usually you don't see
pawn to c3 after pawn to e4 and the
Sicilian defense unless it's kind of
that Ponzi on e opening meaning it's
very early on you usually see it as one
of the first few moves you typically
don't see it as the six move in the game
because in this particular case you know
Anish already has a lot of his pieces
developed on board and so it's gonna be
hard from white to gain the advantage
that he may and the normal pawns iani
opening now from here we see black
castle on the King side getting some
safety and then we see pawn here to h3
which is again also an interesting move
White's not being as aggressive as he
maybe should be the Sicilian offense
from black is a pretty aggressive
defense but white needs to really take
advantage of the fact that he's gone
first after you play pawn to c3 you're
usually looking forward to push forward
with pawn here to d4 really trying to
control the center of the board h3 you
know doesn't have to worry about too
much maybe Knight here to g4 but not
really threatening this pawn here on d7
hasn't moved so it doesn't have to worry
about this LightSquared Bishop coming
down here and pinning down the knight
right away so I would have liked to see
pawn here to d4 this pawn here on c3 is
blocking you know Oscar de la Riva z--
development of his knight here to c3 his
dark squared bishop is gonna be a little
bit awkward to get involved into the
game so h3 seems a little bit passive to
me almost conceding the early moves into
his opponent because he knows he's
playing such a talented player Queen
here to b6 this is a pretty solid move
threatening this Bishop but it also puts
more pressure on the square here on d4
knowing that his opponent would like to
play
here 2d for this kind of stops that is
it's adding more and more pressure to
this square blackmail has his pawn here
his night here on c6 he has a discovered
defense after his Knight moves with his
bishop here on g7 so a lot of different
pieces honing down on the square of d4
where you know a niche knows that white
really wants to go
so the bishops force to come back here
then the rooks wings over here to d8 so
black can actually push forward and
discern the board the bishop comes back
here to b3 still trying to control this
long diagonal right here then pawn here
to d5 trying to control the center of
the board I really like in this puts
York a case if we analyze it the bishop
here on b3 since it's controlling the
center is just taking with this pawn
here on d5 breaking up the center of the
board but instead Oscar decides to play
an interesting move and its pawn here to
e5 the reason I don't like it is because
Knight to e4 is a it's a pain to deal
with I personally would not want to have
to go against this right here it's very
aggressive again black is already kind
of taking control of the aggression in
this game and and so white really has to
find a way to get that advantage back
because right now black is kind of
controlling things
so pawn here to d3 and then pawn to c4
it and pawn to c4 is kind of that next
level play that I think about when it's
kind of a you're really really good at
chess maybe you're even a grandmaster
and then you're this top level play
you're one of the top 10 players in the
world and this pawn here to c4 it is
really great because it attacks his
opponent it recognizes where his
opponent's trying to attack him at and
it also opens up the door with his Queen
here attacking this pawn here on f2
doesn't mind if his opponent takes his
knight he could take this Bishop you
know that's gonna be fine for him if
instead he decides to you know take this
pawn right here then the Queen can come
down force this King to move let's say H
2 then we can see the Queen to g3 it
gets pretty bad for white in this
particular situation so putting a lot of
pressure
on his opponent to find moves early on
it's always gonna be good especially
since black went second this particular
case so the bishops now gonna come to e3
attacking this Queen the queen is forced
to move back so coming back here to c7
this is still a fine square and again
this is also an interesting place in
this board so if we look at it why it is
threatening this night here on e4 but is
Bishop here on b3 is also being attacked
me I'm always bringing my bishop back
here to see to adding more defense on
this pawn here on d3 but I just don't
want to lose my pawn in this particular
game Oscar decides to go ahead and play
Bishop to d4 kind of protecting this
pawn on e5 and trying to make sure that
there there's no sort of breakage on
this D file but then the pawn can just
take here on b3 after the recapture we
have pawn here to f6 and then white
takes the knight back here on e4 so if
we kind of look at material after the
take back here both sides are about
equal in material but black definitely
has a much stronger position on board
he's a lot more aggressive this night
here on b1 still hasn't been developed
on board so it's gonna be it's gonna be
very tough for white to try to find his
way back into this game
in this particular case and these
actually has a lot more time on board
going into the later stages of this
chess game so now we see the knight come
back here to d2 being attacked we see
pawn here to f5 really really
strengthening this pawn chain right here
and if we look from from White's
perspective it's pretty difficult to
find a great move for whites as far as
what why it's really trying to do in
this particular case black on the other
hand he knows he gets the he needs to
get his light squared bishop involved
into the game needs to continue to add
pressure on this D file right here he
needs to get his other rook involved
into the game maybe break up the center
of the board with this Queen and his
bishop right here and just maintain the
pressure on his opponent so we see pawn
here to f3 trying to break up this pawn
chain right here again
not a ton of great moves the White has
on board now black decides to go ahead
and break up the center by sacrificing
his night so after the pawn takes
now this rooks gonna swing down again
black now has an advantage in material
but also if we kind of look at White's
perspective he has two double pawns here
on the B file so not only is he down
material not only is he down on
aggression but also his pawn structure
is a lot worse we now see the pawn
capture and then the pawn to recapture
here on e4 rook taking here on e4 the
route can't take back because the
Knights protecting it right here and
then the nice decides to play Queen here
to b6 now probably a little safer in my
opinion to play Queen back here to d8 he
is again adding a lot of pressure on
this D foul right here Queen to b6 is
fine it's kind of one of those moves of
hey I'm attacking another square I have
a discovered attack if I've moved my
rook right here I'm also defending it
it's one of those like hey I'm really
really good at chess I found this move
even though maybe it's not better I just
want to let you know that I found it
that that's kind of what I think when I
when I see this move but the King's
gonna come over here to h1 you never
want to leave yourself vulnerable to a
discovered attack
now the Bishop to f5 again kind of what
we talked about the game plan for black
is break up the center of the board
get his Livescribe bishop involved he
has the double Bishop pair which is
always good on it open board which is
what we have right here
his opponent still hasn't played this
knight on b1 anywhere on board his rook
on a1 hasn't moved he really hasn't done
much with his Queen right here so much
more aggressive game from black going on
on board right now we now see the rook
being captured the Queen coming in here
the bishop taking on e5 so black is
again up in material he has the double
Bishop pair and now it's just a matter
of adding more and more pressure until
his opponent just resigned so the rook
up here to a4 Queen to d3 Queen over
here to e1 Bishop to g3 again
continuously adding pressure right here
Queen up here to e2
ruk over here to d8 and Oscar de la Rosa
decides in this fatir case sorry Oscar
de la riva decides in this particular
case to go ahead and resign he only had
about three minutes left on board his
opponent had almost 40 minutes on board
so I decided you know he was down to
material playing someone that doesn't
really make mistakes in the endgame
I personally you know always like for
players to finish games out even though
they are down but you know top level
play this is just how players are
decides to go ahead in this position
which is for the most part losing at
this high level decides to go ahead and
resign so and our first match that we
covered a very very great game from the
young twenty-year-old that the Dutchman
great game very very talented player
over there from Oscar de la riva really
really good to see him come in and in
the first match and play well hopefully
he has a good tournament for his country
he kind of leads his team over there
being the best player so hopefully you
guys enjoyed this first match really
excited about the chess olympiad
hopefully we'll have tons of games to
cover but hopefully you learn something
and I'll see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching